[Music]
i started
working at nasa in 1967 and i worked as
a computer
which is how we supported the engineers
then
and the apollo program was actually
starting when i got to nasa
i really enjoyed working with the
equations the equations that sometimes
that they brought into me
were very much like the equations that i
had worked on in graduate school
applied mathematics and i enjoyed
knowing what mathematics and those
equations do in the real world
most of the computers were female and
most of the engineers were male
the engineering division they were given
problems to solve so there was a little
bit of research
involved in what they did and there were
several
high-speed wind tunnels around the
building that we were in it was the
hypersonics area
and so they did research they gave
reports they gave
talks on the research that they were
doing they wrote papers
on the research that they were doing and
they published the papers
the women they did not do research they
basically did what the
engineers asked them to do and the women
did not get promoted
and it was very difficult to get your
name on a paper
after i'd been there several years i
said i wonder
why all of the women are assigned to the
computer office and all of the men
are assigned to the engineering office i
asked my supervisor about transferring
he says no i don't think
you could be able to do that and i
went back to my office i didn't like the
answer that much
i knew it was dangerous and i also knew
that if i went to somebody higher up
that
i could get fired that that they can
fire you for that
and i thought some more and and said
well you know what i think i still think
i should go to a higher up and
if if i get fired i'll go get another
job
and so that's what i did i
went to a director the head of
hypersonic aerodynamics
and i said mr becker i'd really like to
ask you a question if i might i said
i would like to know why a male and a
female coming here with pretty much the
same background
are put in such different positions when
they're here
and he looked at me and he says well you
know nobody has ever asked that question
before
and i said well i'm asking it now
you know and um pretty much that that
was
the end of the conversation and i went
back to my office
and again in about three weeks i
got promoted and i got transferred to
engineering
[Music]
i came to specialize in sonic boom
because when i was transferred to the
engineering section
sonic boom was a big issue in this world
we were supposed to be building a
commercial supersonic transport
but they had just canceled the program
because of the loudness of the sonic
boom
toulouse concourse one made her most
important public appearance back end
first
she was being nosed out of her hangar by
a tractor on the day for which britain
and france and the rest of the world
had waited so long the great giant
supersonic jetliner was going to fly
so now i say to the sst developers
i do not believe this nation will
tolerate
sonic booms and they had put a law on
the book that said there could be no
supersonic commercial flight across the
continental united states nasa says can
we reduce that sonic boom such this
doesn't happen
and i was put in a section that was
going to work on
trying to reduce the sonic bone
[Music]
i'm dr darden an engineer here at nasa
langley research center
i've done sonic boom research here for
many many years
what's a sonic boom doesn't it have to
do with the speed of airplanes
yes it does when an airplane travels
through the air it generates pressure
waves that travel at the speed of sound
in all directions
a plane flying at the speed of sound
moves at the same
speed as the disturbances causing a
shock wave to form
when the plane flies faster than the
speed of sound
the shock wave forms a cone shape
attached to the nose of the airplane
air pressure just inside the cone is
high and air pressure ahead of the cone
is normal this shock wave or cone
extends to the ground
perhaps 10 to 15 miles the sonic boom is
heard when the sudden change in pressure
crosses your ear
the young women who are who find out
that they really enjoy this they enjoy
what it does
i think you need to make sure that you
have learned
your math and your science well and you
speak up about
what you're doing and speak up about
what you want to do don't let
don't let yourself be bullied i think by
the young men in your class and things
like that
i understand that there are still a
number of young women who are leaving
engineering areas because
i guess there's a cross sometimes it's
from their classmates their male
classmates
sometimes apparently it's from some of
their male teachers
the four ps the perceive of yourself in
that job
plan what it is you have to do to get
there start preparing
that plan and persist
solve the problems you encounter and and
take a detour whatever it is you have to
do to not quit
keep going and persist in that job and
let it work out for you which is what
happened to me